mesdames et messieurs bonsoir malgré mon
grand sourire je vais vous annoncer une
nouvelle terrible le bonheur au travail
n'existe pas je dirais même plus le
bonheur au travail est une vaste
supercherie c'est dommage c'était une
belle idée arrive à combiner le bonheur
la plénitude
c'est ce sentiment de satisfaction
totale avec le travail qui est souvent
caractérisée par son étymologie le
tripalium l'instrument de torture arrive
à combiner ces deux éléments
c'était un très très beau projet et
pourtant quand on s'y intéresse vraiment
on se rend compte que on est quand même
sur n'ayons pas peur des mots sur une
vraie fumisterie
je vais m'expliquer
si on s'intéresse un peu à la santé
mentale au travail on se rend compte que
certains concepts sont apparus depuis
quelques années avant les années 90 on
en parle et on n'en parlait pas et
stressés au travail du dr une hérésie
ensuite est apparu le concept d'
harcèlement au travail notamment avec
eux suite à l' ouvrage de marie france
hirigoyen le sur le harcèlement moral au
travail
on a commencé à parler un peu de ces
travaux-là ensuite plusieurs concepts
sont apparus le stress la souffrance au
travail
les risques psychosociaux les fameux rps
notamment suite aux évènements ou à les
appeler comme ça chez france télécom on
a commencé à parler de plus en plus de
ces éléments là pour qu'au détour des
années 2010 on a commencé à voir le
verre à moitié plein bien-être qualité
de vie au travail que l'été est enfin ce
fameux bonheur au travail
quand on creuse un peu encore encore un
peu plus qu'est ce que l'on met derrière
ce ce bonheur au travail des baby foots
des tables de ping pong
parfois on va repeindre certains murs m
des poufs ou des fauteuils de plusieurs
couleurs dans les entreprises parfois
même on désigne un chief happiness
officer peut-être que certains rentrent
un responsable du bonheur au travail
responsable du bonheur au travail
je ne sais pas vous moi je l'imaginé
comme ça soyez heureux
soyez heureux pourtant ces entreprises
qui ont développé cette politique de
bonheur au travail encore une fois qui
est super prometteuse quand on
s'intéresse un peu quand on regarde les
différents indicateurs classiques
accidents du travail arrêt travail taux
d'absentéisme taux de turnover les
indicateurs sont toujours aussi
compliqué on ne note pas réellement
d'amélioration de ses de ces indicateurs
dansez dansez entreprises qui se vente
qui communiquent sur le fait de réaliser
une politique de bonheur au travail et
quand on continue encore à s'y
intéresser à creuser en tant que
chercheur qui se respecte quand on
continue à creuser on se rend compte que
même certaines conséquences peuvent être
encore plus délétère parfois même le
bonheur peut créer le malheur parfois
même le fait de développer une politique
de bonheur au travail est une stratégie
une injonction au bonheur comme je les
dis soyez heureux ce qui amène à l'idée
que si vous n'êtes pas heureux
l'entreprise a quand même tout mis en
oeuvre pour que vous soyez heureux si
vous n'êtes pas heureux c'est de votre
faute
si vous n'êtes pas heureux avec ce baby
foot ce ping-pong sa table de ping pong
avec ses murs de toutes les couleurs
avec cette politique de bonheur au
travail c'est de votre faute et donc on
voit toute la dimension stratégique
toute cette toute cette réalité derrière
ce concept encore une fois très
prometteur de bonheur au travail mais
également il ya évidemment cette
dimension de communication apparaît
c'est le plus haut dans les fameux
classement great place to work
vous connaissez ces classements
ces classements ou les best workplaces
yves les les entreprises où il fait bon
vivre quand on s'intéresse un peu assez
assez assez classement quand on regarde
quelles sont les entreprises je ne vais
pas les citer sait jamais quand on
regarde c'est que mais le classement est
disponible
quand on regarde ces classements quand
on regarde les entreprises qui sont dans
l'est dans les dix premiers 15 promis on
se rend compte qu'à des entreprises qui
sont pas forcément réputé comme étant
des entreprises réellement qu'ils
défendent absolument l'état la place de
l'être humain dans l'organisation va
formuler ça comme ça quand on
s'intéresse à la manière dont sont
tentés constituer ce classement
tout d'abord c'est du déclaratif des
entreprises elles mêmes déclare ensuite
ya quelques experts qui se mobilisent
mais bon et surtout ça met en évidence
un phénomène que nous avons choisi avec
mon co auteur avec jean christophe vue à
tous de l'université de poitiers
on a proposé un concept qui s'appelle
qui s'appelle parmi le green washing
peut-être que ça fait écho un concept
existant le greenwashing connaissait ce
concept
le concept du greenwashing qui voudrait
que des entreprises communiquent sur le
fait de respecter l'environnement de
développer des pratiques en lien avec
l'écologie et que dans les faits
soit beaucoup moins reluisante eh bien
nous avons souhaité proposer un concept
qui reprenait un peu cette structure fin
de cette forme de great wall shing où
les entreprises développent une
communication fantastique autour de la
santé au travail du bonheur au travail
et quand on creuse encore une fois sur
les pratiques réelles et sur la manière
dont ça se passe dans l'entreprise qu'on
se rend compte que l'écart est de plus
en plus important et donc le l'important
au delà du bonheur au travail
au delà de même de la cuvette et du
bien-être etc etc
revenons à l'essentiel revenons à
l'analyse à l'étude à la mise en débat
de l'activité du travail souvent les
ergonomes appelle ça le travail réel
c'est à dire la manière dont le travail
se passe réellement toutes les
difficultés que vous avez d'envoi dans
votre activité travail dans sa
réalisation
toutes ces contradictions tous et toutes
ces éléments qu'on n'arrive pas
forcément anticipé en étant trop
éloignés de la réalité travail rht
parlant du travail dans l'entreprise
de plus en plus on voit émerger et c'est
très bien des espaces de discussions qui
ont pour objectif de débattre du travail
de débats de l'activité travail n'ont
pas de passer par des artifices
managériaux parce que le bonheur au
travail est un artifice managériale
n'ont pas de repasser par là mais de
remettre le l'activité travail au centre
des discussions de reparler dans
l'entreprise on se rend compte qu'on
avait à l'ère de la communication ne
communique plus dans l'entreprise
reparler du travail redébattre remettre
le sens au travail et le sens du travail
au coeur de la réflexion
c'est ce qui est prioritaire et une fois
que l'on aura fait tout cela peut-être
qu'on pourra se permettre une petite
partie de baby la safra tard on pourra
se le permettre je vous remercie pour
attention
[Applaudissements]